to encounter
misfortune
and then prevail
is good fortune to become a successful
businessman you might be faced so many
problems and failures how did you
overcome all the obstacles in your life
okay well that's a good question
um
[Music]
yeah i mean i think the uh
their failure is one of the two sides of
the coins you know you're going to have
success you're going to have failure
it's going to happen
and um
there was a um
there was a roman emperor
marcus aurelius
not part of cbse curriculum
and uh
so many of you probably never heard of
him
um did any of you see the movie
gladiator
gladiator no
also not playing in your hometown
so
uh
so
marcus aurelius was a roman emperor who
spent almost his whole life
on the battlefield
one war after another in his
in his time there were a lot of wars
and
he had a lot of failures
he personally got injured a lot he was
sick a lot of the time
and through all of that
he came up with a philosophy
and the philosophy is known as
the stoic philosophy stoic stoic
philosophy
and there's something known as stoichism
which he came up with
and
the the crux of the philosophy is
that
to encounter
misfortune
and then prevail
is good fortune
so
marcus always believed that when we
encounter failure
we should treat it as a blessing
so failure
is something to be
just embraced
and
what we have to do is we have to
overcome that failure
and when we overcome that failure we go
through growth
we don't go through growth by success we
go through growth by failure
so
so
the best thing about life is
if you get success no problem things are
great
if you get failure also no problem
because you're going to use it
to get better so either way whatever
happens
is not going to
affect you
and you should not let it so i think
that when you encounter adversity
failure
you get bad marks on a test or whatever
else happens
you use it
to
how can i improve from this and how can
i get past it now if you just take the
test result and get depressed
and
don't do anything
then
that's not good
you have to push and take it from there
[Music]
[Music]
you